[Music]
welcome
uh sag members here and uh i hope you
enjoyed palm springs one of the
best comedies in a long time and we have
the two stars here
uh to talk about i'm very happy about
that first off andy sandberg who plays
niles
hello hey and as sarah
kristen miliate hi hi
i know you've talked about this uh a lot
since uh it hit fun dance
uh but there's so much to talk about i
have to say you walked into sundance
with this movie and walked out with a
record
it sold for the biggest amount of money
in the history
of that film festival that has to feel
pretty good it felt fantastic i think it
was
uh very fortunate for us that we hit uh
we arrived at sundance in a moment when
there's a lot of streamers trying to
really you know mark their territory and
sort of announce themselves as serious
about movies
um and we had luckily a fun movie that
that people were interested in
yeah i'll say uh i think they said by
about 69 cents you you hit the record
i don't know how precise that is but uh
yeah that's
on brand with the movie i think right
normally we associate your films uh in a
lot of ways with lonely island
and and that whole um thing your
creative setup there this one came about
differently didn't it
it did yes it was um a script that came
to me
you know just asking if i wanted to act
in it and or
possibly produce but it's totally you
know
something that i felt like it was in my
wheelhouse but not quite as
broad or arched comedically as some of
that other stuff there's a lot
i i don't want to disparage the lonely
island stuff but i feel like this has a
little bit more on its mind it's
you know it's a little more serious it
blends genres a little bit more
uh there's an existential dread to it um
which i think was something that we all
were really excited about
what about for you kristin what about
this character of sarah she's complex
well that's one of the things that i
really loved about her is that
you know she you sort of um you get to
see the whole spectrum with her
like i i got to play um every aspect of
a human going through a variety of
things and she's so
flawed you understand how she got
herself in the position she's in and why
she's so desperate to escape it
you know when i read it i was like oh my
god this is there is so much here to
dig into um what an incredible
opportunity
and then also to work with andy who i'd
met with um
and i thought that the script was so
singular and unique
that's also one of the things that i
loved so much about sarah is that
everyone knows
regardless of whether you are on the
same path as her
you know what it's like to feel like
you're like boiled in your own shame
and i think something she does um as a
defense mechanism which i had a lot of
compassion for and understanding for
you know we are all guilty of this at
various times too of like
it's everyone's fault but mine of like
not wanting to look at your own
culpability in something it's why i've
always felt like
this movie is you know when we do press
for it they ask
they're like oh it's a romantic comedy
and i've always thought of it more as an
existential comedy and it
actually kind of a zen movie that like
you can't
run away from anything you have to like
come back to yourself and that all
you're left with is
yourself and um i felt like that
with her the pain of not wanting to
accept that was one of my favorite parts
of the film
i loved the role of niles because
it was something that i was comfortable
with comedically and i knew i had that
to fall back on
you know periodically throughout the
movie
but i also just love the bait and switch
of him emotionally and
sort of like what you think he is when
you first meet him versus what you come
to realize about him
which is he seems like you know he's in
charge of it all he's got it all figured
out he's totally zen and he's totally
at peace but the truth is you're looking
at a character who is
so broken yeah that he is completely
given up
and to me like in a very sad way that
was very funny also
i was like i've never seen exactly that
tone
written in this way you know where it
was making me laugh but also my heart
really broke for him where
you're not sure if he even really does
remember his own life or
who he was and what he was about and you
kind of get the feeling he's okay with
it because he wasn't really happy with
it
you know there's little hints teed up
throughout he's in a relationship that's
clearly not
working and he's allowing that to just
sort of happen to him
and you get the sense he was allowing
that to happen before he got stuck
so there's this wonderful metaphor that
our writer andy ciara
threads through the whole thing for both
of us which is they're stuck
and they're stuck yeah and you know it's
yeah the time loop is almost like
irrelevant exactly
exactly and the decision they make at
the end
is it doesn't matter what happens after
it's that they made the decision is what
matters that they decided to
you know be participants in their own
lives choose to forgive themselves
choose to believe they
are deserving of love and happiness and
choose to do that together
was that the original ending or did you
have others i would imagine this kind of
story would lend itself
to a couple of ways to end it at least
there were many different versions of
the very end
you know the post cave yeah we shot a
bunch of different endings
yes but ultimately
even in the first draft i saw which
structurally the third act changed a lot
when we all worked on it together and
did a rewrite
the the main choice of the two of them
together
choosing each other and choosing to
brave
moving forward together in one way shape
or form was intact
um and then we kind of amped it up once
we had financing
[Laughter]
what was your favorite moment that you
sort of got to do uh
you know on the fly that wasn't in the
script my favorite thing
personally which uh
was the scene that you're talking about
like on the fly
yeah yeah um because i have favorite
things that i like got to do in this
movie but
on the thing on the fly was that there's
the scene where we're like it's in the
montage where
andy's like i'm a bomb guy with a cake
and i'm the villain and i didn't tell
him that i was going to have like a hook
and an eye patch and an accent
because it was like part of the that
niles wouldn't know that and that like
sarah was able to get that stuff at like
a cvs down the road
and like that was hilarious and fun also
like we
collaborated on the um the dick tattoos
like which we stole that was like one of
the most like did we
i can't remember though andy did i like
i know we had that
was that day of or was that like the day
before that that happened
we had been talking about really wanting
to have a moment where they give each
other tattoos
talking about like if you had a day
where you could do anything and then it
resets
and there's no repercussion tattoo is
like a big one you'd be like
yeah i would love to know what that
experience is like yeah
and then we were like well what's the
like the nightmare version of that that
you can then laugh about because it's
not real forever
was him asking for a cool tattoo and her
drawing a dick on him
and then we were like well if we're
gonna do that
we should have him doing it too but then
we were excited about the idea that she
was asking specifically for a dick
tattoo
yeah and like we stole that shot as we
were
losing light like out in the desert and
it was like part of the like
mad cap i don't know there was um i felt
like so free with andy as a partner that
like we were constantly talking about
this stuff because also we're like stuck
in a car
a million hours a day like we have like
we're running lines constantly because
we had a
very brutally short shoot so we were
constantly running lines constantly
running scenes
i think that that energy is like in
there a short
a short version of what we're saying is
we never considered the script locked we
kept trying to add and
and you know figure out new angles on
things and
you know we added certain scenes that
ended up in the movie
you know during shooting we'd like jot
them down on our phones and then hand it
to the actors and we'd give them a try
and some of that stuff worked and some
didn't
yeah did you have to cut out a lot or or
was most of the script in there or
you know do stuff in the editing room
most of it is in there some of it got
repurposed and sort of rearranged
which i have to say on a really short
schedule was kind of the blessing
of having it be a loop where a lot of
footage is at the same locations
right so you could you know sort of dip
into reaction passes and and move them
to other scenes when you need them and
you need to bridge a shot and that kind
of stuff
the most glaring one was we had kristin
memorize this really long
you know scientific run
in the scene where she's explaining why
her plan might work
um and we consulted you know with a a
real scientist
yeah and worked out a lot of stuff you
know about the cauchy horizon and all
this stuff
and yeah and black holes and yeah
yeah and you know inter
interdeterministic
i said it wrong but you get the idea
deterministic i used to know the whole
thing yeah
yes and a lot of it you know within the
rules of the world we created really
tracked and
we were all really excited about and it
made sense and kristen did a great job
with it
and then when we started doing our
friends and family screenings and kind
of feeling it out we
realized people just were good without
it
you know they were more tracking the
emotional story yeah um so that
that was probably the biggest lift i
don't think there's a single whole
scene we cut though most of it ended up
on screen
so all that work with quantum physics
and all of that
uh is up for the blu-ray yes yeah
it's for the blu-ray yeah i feel like
we keep talking about this i bet you if
you thought it'd be like 25 30 seconds
that we cut out
i think so god it felt like i mean i
spent days memorizing that monologue
it felt long it was dense dense stuff
yeah done stuff
i loved the whole concept of time loop
of course groundhog day russian doll
more recently yeah it's been used this
one felt very fresh to me for some
reason it's not like okay i've seen this
they're kind of copying a genre it's
becoming a genre
yeah it seemed like it served the story
and it served these characters
uh in that way uh well good that was
certainly our hope
um you know when when the script first
came
to to me and to our company
we didn't know about this new wave of
them that was coming
you know i joked with natasha like
i probably should have checked in with
you to see what you're up to because
russian doll was really [ __ ] good
and we didn't know it existed when we
took the movie on um
but you know in our mind it was like
okay there's groundhog day then there
was edge of tomorrow which is the sci-fi
version
and then will be like the hard r version
that's like
kind of indie and edgy and then by the
time we were actually shooting we were
like oh man there's a lot of time loop
stuff
but then as after we shot even more came
out and we were like
i think we actually might be okay
because now there's so many
that like you say i think it's kind of
just become its own
category and we felt the more we watched
the more
ours really did kind of define itself on
its own terms
i've known max barberko since he was
much younger and growing up in santa
barbara
and uh you know and then so when i heard
he got a movie like i knew he went to
afi and he did some great shorts and
things
what was that like you're bringing in
not lonely island here
he's a first feature film director yes
i mean they came together max and andy
they were at afi together and they
conceived this
movie together and you know brainstormed
it a bunch and so the deal from day one
was
here's this script and here's the
director
and he hasn't made a movie but he made
this short film and we were like
okay we loved the script and we met with
both of them and we were like
it just feels good like everyone's on
the same page
we've got a good infrastructure here
just in case you know
we've got akiva as a producer who is a
very talented director so he knows a lot
you've got me who
produced a lot and we were just off and
running you know we
we hired a great dp in in q tran who
killed it and her and max were on the
same page
immediately and the thing we've been
saying a lot and it really was true was
it was just one of those fortunate
situations creatively where
we were all in it together from the jump
we all saw it
really similarly i think the reason andy
and max were excited to do the movie
with us
was because when we first met we were
saying what they wanted to hear
tonally and you know
it was a little outside the the normal
thing that i would do you know we knew
coming in we were gonna have a low
budget
um and that the scheduling was gonna be
really hard
and the scheduling was really hard
but when it comes down to it
when you got into that editing room we
have great shots
and great performances and the movie
works you know that's
uh i don't i don't feel trepidation
saying that i've worked on a lot of
things where i came out the other end
and i was like i don't know if it worked
but i feel like this one
we we made the thing that on day one
when we all met
we wanted to make um and a huge part of
that goes to max
and andy obviously but it's their movie
they they conceived the whole thing
i'm curious so you said you didn't have
that much time to shoot it how much time
did you have how much pressure
was on you to pull this thing off i
believe the the
shoot was 21 days wow yeah
yeah that's no joke it was re it was
real but
but you know everybody was just about
their business everyone came
came really strong and
you know that's the kind of thing you
can do when you have a script you
believe in
mm-hmm yeah and when you come and when
you have a company that's as much
on the same page like you know we've
said this before
in interviews too and it's just because
it was so overwhelming like no one got
you know no one was doing this for the
money
except jk but um but like the whole crew
like
we were out there like in these brutal
elements and everyone believed in this
and believed in this story and like just
threw it all
at the wall and like not to sound sort
of like pollyanna about it but actually
like the
the zaniness of that of that shoot the
how fast we had to do it like you kind
of had to just everyone was going with
like their first instinct and everyone
had done like a lot of prep with it too
and um it actually was kind of like an
incredible
i mean i don't know i can only speak for
myself but like uh you just kind of
gotta like
let go and it all came together i think
because we all
i don't know it's like one of like the
magic fairy dust things about making
something
that you can never predict but that like
we all sort of were in the same
world or whatever was it always called
palm springs because the title is
it you know i mean it doesn't really
tell you you know going in cold what
this movie is going to be about was
there a thoughts of other titles or
did you just like that it was always
palm springs
and we always loved it it was a few
times
it would come up casually in
conversation
and i would always say
sure let's talk about it what else you
got and no one really could ever come up
with anything we like better
[Laughter]
because i don't know there's just
something so clean about it
yeah you know and it's a gamble you're
like you know if if people don't like
the movie it's
really going to be in trouble with the
title but if they do then it has a
chance to just be nice and clean and
like
now there's something called palm
springs and it's this yeah
well now that this is over do you guys
want to work together again do you have
anything going on
no no no no we're good one and done
one and done no i was constantly
pitching andy
the whole time i was like so the next
thing that we do together let's make
this a thing
let's be like uh you know catherine
hepburn
spencer tracy oh thank you like
i was like you know let's let's let's do
this let's make this a thing
yeah i pitched all types of stuff to you
we're excited and he fell on
deaf ears and he was very clear that he
was not interested
i was always listening to my headphones
and she just didn't know and i'd be like
what yeah uh
we don't have anything yet but we want
to it's
we're gonna we're gonna try we're now
we're actor friends
yeah we're to do a comedic version of
who's afraid of virginia woolf and like
that'll be fun i don't eat that either
yeah i'll start drinking now
congratulations on this this has been uh
go in front of mine for a lot of people
all the way since it debuted at sundance
and it's still going strong on hulu i
should mention hulu
um and uh and uh thanks for uh joining
us here for this uh
sag conversation today with your fellow
actors thank you
thank you really appreciate it